let's talk about the state of this
country yeah we got the story from
timcast.com
rnc sues two vermont towns for allowing
non-citizens to vote the governor's veto
of the measure was overruled by the
state's legislature they say montpellier
and winooski recently altered their
charters so non-citizens who immigrated
legally could vote in municipal
elections
how's that for you have no country
that's like the opposite direction of
where i want to go i want you to have to
live there for four years before you can
start voting there wait wait at least
could you be a citizen first how about
that be a citizen and have some
residence in the area where you're
voting wait can you please say that to
me one more time did you just tell me
that there are jurisdictions in the
united states where it is now legal to
vote if you're not a citizen yes there
are many actually there's a lot of them
exact i think sacramento's got a couple
san francisco got a couple those are
those are municipal elections
so there's like school board and stuff
like that yeah look look
the left will come out and be like it
used to be in this country you had to be
a landowner to vote those yeah bigots
and it's like
let me just let me just let's just break
this down real quick you're in the
middle of the woods there's a bunch of
people walking around and you're like
all right we're gonna have a vote on
what to do about that tree that fell
down and then a bunch of will walk up
and they're like i'd like to vote do you
live here yes where do you live um okay
look only the people who live here get
to vote oh that's racist you're bigoted
it's like
the reason they did it that they had
that system was because
if you lived there you voted but now you
see like matt walsh just poked a big
hole in that did you see he wanted to go
speak a lot i think it's loudoun county
and then they wouldn't let him because
he wasn't a resident so he rented
property and he's like now i'm a
resident but it's like okay he's showing
that you really should have to live
there for like four years
a long period of time i've actually
looked into this a few times now i want
to have more clarification i'm gonna
tell one story real quick we've been
looking at jurisdictions to buy land
maybe jurisdictions with not a lot of
people in them that have sheriff's
offices and school boards and stuff so
maybe we move enough people there we
take over a sheriff's office right how
cool would that be
so a lot of these jurisdictions they are
the the um
the requirement for voting is that you
have moved there with the intention of
remaining that's it
now you're telling me that these could
be non-us citizens yes
just foreigners that showed up came to
the meeting and said i'm here now i
would like to vote
yes
are they renting property is that the
montpellier bill allows what is defined
as a legal resident of the united states
to be able to vote in city elections if
someone is here on a permanent basis why
would he or she not want to participate
in the process to become a citizen okay
so they have to have a green card i
guess it says legal immigrants yes i see
it doesn't matter as far as i'm
concerned right they're still not u.s
citizens you have to be a u.s citizen
yes exactly yeah yeah
the idea that you shouldn't have no i
know it's really insane really simple
they er they they are
you know man i got a friend
argue all the time because he was just
all on board for biden
he goes on twitter he goes on facebook
he's screaming trump is bad we gotta
vote for biden and then guess what he
did it a couple months after the
election ended he moved to europe
that is the problem when people are like
everyone please vote for this thing and
as soon as it happens they're like later
suckers
wow now we're watching this this this
free fall economic crisis labor
shortages gas prices inflation the
border afghanistan and the people who
vote for it at least this one guy is
like i'm out
later [ __ ] yeah thanks appreciate it
i kind of get the idea of a locality
maintaining its autonomy and if like if
they want to let foreign citizens vote
in local locale then do it who's to say
you can't you know but so maybe it
should be on a pace but i can imagine
someone getting in there and co-opting
it and being like yes now we can all yes
people are like no yeah well pretty soon
here's here's the issue ian you've got
10 people who live in a house and they
all just they won't they want to vote
for what's what's for lunch they all
pitch in every day they put a dollar in
the lunch bucket and so they're like
okay it's lunch time we got 10 what
should we buy from and then someone says
well why don't we let you know jim he's
our neighbor he doesn't live here but he
can jimmy mack jimmy
so what happens is jimmy mack then says
i would like to to vote that we allow my
my brother to vote as well and so let's
put it to a vote when you allow someone
from outside to vote on very specific
internal issues they will of course vote
for their own interest so when you say
non-citizens can vote they'll be like i
would like to vote in this election yes
i'd like to vote yes on allowing more
people who aren't citizens to vote
why wouldn't they people are going to
vote for what they think is best for
them it's kind of like community in that
metaphor to be like a house of 10 people
and then like another guy moves in an
eleventh person who doesn't his name's
not on the lease but you give him voting
power he doesn't even move in
it's the delivery guy who drops off
lunch he's at the door and everyone's
like well we have to vote oh we have to
include him now we have 11 people voting
but this is people with green cards that
live there yeah in the in the in so but
if someone's not a citizen there's less
of a guarantee that they're in it for
the long run let's guarantee that
they're going to be assisting try again
there's 10 people in a big house and
then you know jimmy mack is sleeping on
the couch
yeah he's on the lease we don't know
what his plan is he's just crashing here
half the people here are really pissed
off about it they're like dude i pay
rent i don't want some dude what if i'm
gonna have somebody over and he's on the
couch and then they're like okay we all
pooled our resources to buy a dinner
well he should he's here should be
allowed to vote on what we eat and
you're like oh come on and then what
happens is there is like there's a
meeting in the house and they say who
should be allowed to vote on what we eat
and then they're like we should allow
him to vote too it it it includes him
and then he says oh i got some friends
who are going to be hanging out uh i
think they should be allowed to decide i
mean they're going to be here too and
then in a few months all of a sudden
there's 15 people who don't live there
out voting the 10 who do
this is why we have
restrictions not because we hate people
or we we oppose freedom or we're bigots
it's because we're literally like hey
economy means household management from
the greek economia so we're quite
literally talking about managing the
household in an effective way so that we
are growing not collapsing but when you
allow people who don't live to come in
they're going to be like uh i vote to
eat his portion and then they take it
then they leave
so people need to have ties to the
community so yes you have to live there
for a certain amount of time or be a
citizen a legal resident is is what
they're talking about is eroding the
system you can live here but you're not
a citizen you want to become a citizen
you can go through the process then you
are a full-fledged member of our
community we're going to allow you to
stay so if someone wants to crash in my
house and sleep on the couch for a
little bit but a little bit that's fine
but they're not going to be voting on
what you know cable provider we're going
to be getting if they want to move in
put a deposit down pay rent we'll talk
about them being a full resident or you
could say people with green cards have
to go through a different process other
than citizenship that will allow them to
vote in their local communities
i'm just saying if you're not a citizen
you should not be able to vote and it's
not as if
granting these people who are not
american citizens the right to vote in
any election is going to be the end of
it and the left is going to go okay they
have the adequate rights that we should
be giving to non-citizens they're just
going to keep pushing to give them more
voting power in other situations they'll
go oh see we allow them to vote in local
elections why not state elections why
not national elections right they do not
stop right the new federal requirement
for voting in the presidential election
will be are you eligible to vote in any
jurisdiction in america yep yeah and you
know uh and then when the republicans
are like we don't think this is good the
democrats are going to go
they're just suppressing voter rights
voting they're suppressing voter rights
that's exactly what dude it is
absolutely insane when you look at how
far our system of election has been
eroded and destroyed and now we're at
the point where there's universal
mail-in voting which the left will tell
you makes it easier for everyone to vote
it makes it easier for a whole first of
all including people who shouldn't vote
let's
let's i'm not gonna go there i'm gonna
tell you this
when you live in a city with extreme
population density two activists can hit
a thousand uh doors knocking on those
doors to advocate for their candidate
and a republican would require ten times
the amount of distance and energy and
money to cover because they're rural and
they're spaced out that alone
should be a red flag as to why we need
some kind of standard uniform process
for voting that we actually assess what
i mean by that is
it shouldn't be well actually i should
rephrase that it shouldn't be just this
blanket everyone gets to do x because it
doesn't affect every area the same way
money is used differently in different
jurisdictions the reason why the
democrats are so dead set one of the
reasons universal mail and voting is not
because and i know a lot of people on
the right get mad about this
mass fraud or anything that that's not
it there's certainly issues a guy got
arrested at 300 ballots in the
recollection in his car he got charged
with forgery that stuff happens but one
activist for the democrats can go into
one apartment complex and secure a
thousand votes by advocacy which is
legal and normal but a republican in a
republican jurisdiction
has to cover 10 square miles get the
same amount of people meaning no matter
the republicans have to spend 10 times
the money or some exponentially greater
number to cover that ground
that system does not work how about
first pass the post voting doesn't work
we need ranked choice or a different
system i don't even know if ranked
choice is perfect but it's probably
better than what we got yeah it is and
then you have to go to a voting station
and there should be voting stations set
up per population so if it's in a big
city and it's for every you know every
30 000 people you set up a one voting
station so that means in dense areas
you'll have 50 all within a couple
blocks and in rural areas you'll have 15
within a couple blocks instead of just
saying we mail it to everybody
yep i was thinking do we do with one
person one vote and the ranked choice
kind of automatically does that yeah one
person one vote makes no sense it's i
understand why you know the founders may
have thought that made sense back in the
day it's a very simple system but it
ultimately results in people being like
i have no choice but to vote for this
awful person
if you were able to actually be like
here are my values ranked out ranked
choice voting is better it's not perfect
there are still circumstances in which
people vote for the lesser of two evils
you know but i i i do think rank choice
makes more sense i think maine does it
this way i think i'm not sure maybe
nebraska there's a couple places that
are implementing ranked choice is this a
new development or is this something
that's been around for a while right
choice no the these non-us citizens
voting in localities so uh over the past
couple of years we've seen stories out
of you know california and new york
where they allow this and they say it's
just for like schools and things like
this it makes sense because they have
kids in the schools and you go oh okay i
guess that makes sense and the next day
they go look the kids are in the schools
they're using the streets they're
driving on buses they should have a say
in how taxes are being spent their kids
are already they already vote on the
school board one by one they will keep
pushing until eventually it's like how
long have you been here sir i just got
here 15 minutes ago from el salvador uh
here's your voter card and uh thank you
for choosing our president
yeah no well you know part of this comes
from the supreme court decision that
says that anybody that shows up on the
school house steps
must be educated
right did you know that one point in
time you had to be a citizen to get
educated interesting yeah now literally
anybody who shows up at the door and it
can say it can show that they live here
like here's my power bill or whatever
you mean at a public school though
probably yeah yeah of course yeah
anybody taking tax money out of any
citizen no matter of immigration status
legal illegal whatever you show up you
get an education you get fed school
lunch program participate in after
school activities all the things and you
know back in the day hundreds of years
ago
there were no harshly controlled borders
you could walk on in to new york and
they'd be like are you citizens no and
they'd be like well then you can't work
here or you can't live here things like
that but you could basically move about
with little issue and now
i think people need to understand the
exponential growth and population and
what that really means it changes things
yes however the point was you could be
there and they'd be like look
we have citizens the reason they're
citizens is because we know who's a part
of the community who's pitching in who's
doing the work who's serving in who's
being conscripted who's in the fire
brigade
we can't have some strange person who's
not a part of this coming in and
changing what we do so they have these
rules i think people need to understand
though the the scale of population
growth there were two million people in
the colonies at the time of the
revolution there's 320 million now
i mean that is
it is insane
we see these massive protests yo if an
occupy wall street protest when they had
like you know 20 000 people marching
through the street
if that group of people were marching on
a battlefield they'd be like what great
country has such a mighty force
it's like oh that's a bunch of college
kids who are bored yeah right yeah you
know back oh so it'll be easy for us
except for their numbers
population growth has been absolutely
insane
yeah people don't you know what i was
thinking about too with population
growth stuff
you used to how many people did you know
back then hundreds of years ago when
there were barely any people you'd know
like 30 people well you also weren't
connected to everyone through the
internet too so you didn't know about
the people in the next town over on the
other coast or around yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time